So this first one is actually false.
We don't know that the shortest tour for the input graph has length 1056.
That's the smallest one that we happen to have found,
but if we ran the algorithm numerous more times,
then we might find a smaller one,
and the only thing we know for certain is that
the minimal vertex cover is at least 618
because of our factor 2 approximation.
We also don't know that the random algorithm is likely a factor 3 approximation,
again because we would need to run it
many, many more times to really be certain of that.
Now we have found a tour that is at most
1.71 times as long as the optimal one
because we found a tour of length 1056,
and we know that the optimal one is at least 618,
which is 1.71.
Now we have not found a tour that is at most
1.43 times as long as the optimal one,
and if we plug that into our previous equation and we solve it for X,
then we would get X equals 1.43 times 618,
which is about 883,
which we didn't find a tour of 883.
So that is not true.